hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the world's quietest
let's play it sounds like this pop rocks
in my mouth come along little Johnny it
has been awhile I hope you don't mind
the bumpy ride it blowing upon Johnny
come back here you little [ __ ]
Wow it seems I've found the secret to
suck ooh
five balls it seems my medical condition
has worsened by a factor of 2.5 no you
bag of tits you son of a [ __ ] how dare
you mash my face if I have to do this
[ __ ] again I'll tear off your entire
ass and then feed it to yourself if you
could stop ruining my butthole what did
I just say my vengeance will be endless
you will see Horrors on you sack of [ __ ]
social Johnny who's not muck listen tell
me if you've dodged this next one I will
officially stop hating on you victory is
assured there's no way that I can [ __ ]
this up
[Music]
this is Oni
what have you done to become immune to
my Swartz I don't like that no no I'm
gonna come on your teeth